[Music]
welcome everybody to our final
presentation in this programming track i
want to introduce you to jim hester
jim is a software engineer on the
tidiverse team
and he is going to talk about his work
on github actions
all right thanks everyone for coming um
as andre
said i'm jim hester i'm a software
engineer at rstudio and i'm going to
talk about github actions for r so
github actions is a new service
recently released by github and it
allows you to automate
common workflows in software packages
and in repositories that you have on
github
and one of the most common things that
people want to do
with these types of services is what's
called continuous integration or ci
and continuous integration is if you're
not familiar with it it's a
it's a way to to run your all the tests
and checks on your project every time
you make a change to the project so
if you commit a change to the repo or if
someone
submits a pull request to your repo
continuous integration
would would run all of the package
checks on that new code to verify that
it doesn't break your existing
functionality
and this is a really great way to make
sure that you don't accidentally break
something
and also to give you confidence that the
user the
the person who submitted the pull
request to you isn't going to break
something
in your project and this is also a good
way to ensure your project is
reproducible because
the code is running on someone else's
machine which is really like one of the
first steps in reproducibility
so martin fowler has this famous quote
um that
if it hurts you should do it more often
and that's really the crux
of of um continuous integration
rather than running your tests maybe
only before you do like a crayon release
or a big release of your package
you run the test every time you make a
change and that really makes sure that
if you if you introduce a bug it's only
going to be a bug
in a very small subset of your package
because it's only the things that have
changed since the last
last time you ran a successful test
so what does this actually look like on
github so um
this is a this is all the commits in one
of my repositories the vroom repository
and i'm and next to each commit you can
see there's
it's kind of small but there's a green
check mark next to some and
or a red x next to some others and um
this is showing the the the check status
of
of the the checks that i ran on github
actions for each of those commits
and if you click on one of these the red
check marks
it'll give you a more detailed view of
all of the checks that were run
so here i'm running checks on multiple
different operating systems and you can
see the windows and mac os
checks worked fine but all of the checks
on linux seems to have broke so clearly
that gives you some idea of
where the problem might lie already and
if you need more detail there's a live
log for the checks and you can
find exactly what what line might have
caused the error
so there's this github actions is not
the only service that provides these
sort of features so why
might github actions be a good thing for
you to try on your repository
um the first thing is that has it's one
of the
few um services that has support for
multiple all three major operating
systems linux windows and mac os
and it also has first class support for
docker containers so if your package or
your project if you're used to working
in docker containers
and you have all of your dependencies
already bundled into a docker container
you can use those on github actions very
easily
it also has very generous resource
allocations for your jobs so you can run
20 concurrent jobs for
for a given repository and those jobs
can take up to six hours
and because github actions is built into
github
it doesn't require separate
authentication and setup steps apart
from your regular github authentication
so
as soon as you commit the configuration
file that describes your workflow
to your repository is going to start
running on github actions you don't have
to do any additional
manual setup and
you might ask is this service free and
it is for
open source academic and educational
repositories
if you're if you don't fall into one of
those buckets you can still use github
actions but you have to pay
a fairly reasonable fee
so i mentioned there were some other
services that do similar things to what
github actions provides
some of the most popular that are used
in the r the r community
are travis ci circle ci and app fair you
can see compared to these github actions
is one of the few that
has support for all of these three
operating systems and really good
support for docker containers
and then it also gives you many more
concurrent builds than the other
services provide for open source
projects
and the maximum job length is is the
longest of any of the other options
and then again in terms of setup because
this is integrated into github
um it's like basically painless to set
up whereas
some of the other services range from
moderately annoying to
extremely annoying
so you might have noticed that in my
talk abstract i
it was about azure pipelines and github
actions so why am i not talking about
azure at all
so the first thing is that it is true
that azure pipelines has been around
as a publicly available service for a
lot longer than github actions so as a
result it's much more mature
there's there's more definitely more
features available in azure
however because it's not um integrated
into github it's actually much more
challenging to set up and get working
on your um on your project and
they actually share the same
infrastructure so github actions is
running on the azure cloud
so and actually the a lot of the code
the back end code is is identical
between the two
services so a lot of the features are
basically the same between the two
and because github actions is so much
easier to
get set up and i think it's just going
the features are just going to continue
to improve over time
i just would recommend using github
actions
so how do you actually do this on your
repository
so in the develop version of the use
this package we have a function called
use github actions
and this will create a workflow
configuration file
these are a yamo file if you're familiar
with that format
and and this describes
two github actions the workflow that you
want it to perform
so at the beginning we have to tell
github actions what
github event we want to run the action
on the workflow on
and so in this case we want to run it
anytime there's a push to the repository
or there's a pull request and the next
thing we
are specifying is what operating system
the workflow should run on in this case
we're running on mac os
and then we need to check out the code
so this checks out your
your get code on the worker and then we
set up r
using this custom action that that i
wrote
to install our on on the worker
and then we need to so this is checking
a pack an r package and those our
packages
usually have additional package they
packages they depend on
so um this set of code is is installing
the remotes package to install all of
the package dependencies for
the r package we're trying to check and
then finally we can actually
run run the check on our package with
the r command check package
so that's like the the sim the simplest
workflow for doing a package check
in the tidy verse we try to have a
little bit more robust checks we want to
check
um on that on more than one operating
system and more than one
um more than one version of ours
so we have this more this lengthier so
this is the entire file which obviously
you can't read
but um i'm gonna go through some of the
features in this so
and this uses a different function use
github actions tidy
so the first thing that this does is
uses a matrix build
which means that instead of only
building one um
one operating system and one version of
r we're building
uh multiple different operating systems
so we're building on windows mac os
and ubuntu linux and then we're also
building on different multiple versions
of r
so it's building on our devel r 3.6
and and all the way back to r 3.2
and we do this in the tidy verse
packages to ensure that all of our
packages work
on even pretty old versions of r
the last thing this has is our studio
package manage it takes advantage of our
studio package manager
which now provides linux binaries so
that really speeds up the installation
of
of installing your package dependencies
on linux
another thing that helps with installing
package dependencies quickly
is package caching which github actions
also provides
and and this code that i'm showing here
is how you set that up
for an r package
another thing that this workflow does is
it automatically will create using the
rhub
sysrex database it automatically queries
any
linux system dependencies that your
package
packages or dependencies needs and will
automatically install them
so rather than having to know about
these
linux system dependencies yourself this
will
query them and install them for you
automatically
and then finally it's often i guess not
quite finally but um
it's when if when a failure happens it's
often useful
to download all of the logs for that
check
run um to your local machine so you can
inspect them more closely
um so this this chunk of code
will if a failure happens it will upload
the
all the check logs as an artifact of the
build so you can download them if you
need to
and then finally we run um
the we use the cover package to run
test coverage on the on the r package
and use the codecov.io service
to upload the results and store the
results of our check coverage
so that was the the more complicated
workflow we also um
so i should mention all of these
workflows that i'm going through are
available on this github site github.com
rlib actions so it has examples of
everything i'm going to be talking about
today
and all of the custom actions that we've
built for our packages
so there's additional workflows that we
have available
so these are three similar workflows for
building
other things related to our packages so
the first one is
a workflow that builds the package down
site for your r package
second one is if you have a blog down
site this will
build this will use github actions to
build your blog down site and deploy it
to netlify and
the third one is if you have a book down
book
you can use github actions to build your
book
and then deploy it to netlify as well so
these are all fairly similar so i'm only
going to go through one of them
the blog down one and you can you
you can add these to your project using
the use this use github action
and then the file name in this case it's
blogdown.yaml
um so that's the full file but
so what this does is the first thing is
it installs r and pan dock
this is very similar to the workflow we
already saw
the next thing is for this block
downside i'm actually going to use the
rn
package to track the the package
dependencies i used in my site
and then install exactly the same
versions that i used locally
on the github actions worker
so that's what this is doing and then
it's also installing the hugo web
framework
that you need to for blog down and then
finally i can build the site using blog
down build
build site and then deploy the site to
netlify
by installing the netlify command line
tool
and then using that to deploy the site
um so the other thing to point out in
this slide
is that i'm using a secret so
github actions lets you add secrets to
your
your repository um in the repository
settings
and then you can use these secrets
within your action workflows
for doing things like like i'm doing
here if i have an authentication token i
need
so all the actions i've sewn so far are
have basically used the same
event so they they're running on either
a push or a pull request event
but you can actually trigger a github
action
on any event in a github repository
so some some examples we have of
triggering things on other events
are an action that will re-render a
readme.rmd file
anytime you modify the contents of that
file
so that won't have that won't run
normally if you're editing something
else in your repository but if
a given commit or pull request edits
something that
in that read me then it will this action
will run and re-render and then actually
it will also
push the results back to the repository
so you don't ever have to do that
rendering locally the second thing
is for it's a it's a
thing to help package maintainers when
they're dealing with pull requests
so we have a custom github action that
that looks for
special comments that the package
maintainer um
posts on on a on a pull request
slash document and slash style and
github actions
uses this event and when those comments
appear it will automatically
run devtools document or use the stylar
package
and restyle uh the pull request and then
push the
the result of those action of that that
that code back to the pull request so
rather than the maintainer having to
download the code locally run like
devtools document commit the results and
push it back
the they can just you comment slash
document
it will github actions will do all of
this and then you can go on with your
code review another example is
on my personal website on jimhester.com
i have this
this github inspired calendar
that is showing like all of my activity
throughout the year and i have to update
this every day
so i i build my site with github actions
and i have
a you can schedule an action to run
at a certain time so i have this this
action running every day at 11 o'clock
and so that way i don't have to like
update this manually every day
so i mentioned github actions has
support for docker containers
so how would that look so this is a
simple example of using a docker
container
in a github action so you have to
specify which container you want to use
and this is pulling
in this case i'm using the rockerverse
container and this is pulling from
the docker hub so this container is
available on docker hub
and it will run all the co all the rest
of the code in that container
so here i'm fitting a model in one r
script and then i'm running
i'm rendering an rmd file and creating
an html output
and then uploading that html output as
an artifact of the build
so this presentation was about github
actions for r
this work is is
was done by me and also we had an r
studio intern max held who did a lot of
the
early pioneering work of this over the
summer so this wouldn't be possible
without him
um all of the workflows that i talked
about are available on
dot com slash rlib actions and that also
has all of our custom actions so if
you're looking for information about
using github actions for r that's the
best place to go
and if you want to try these out on your
repository you can go to use this use
github actions
and the slides are available on speaker
deck at that url so
thank you
that was great thank you very much jim
um the first question is
if you use azure devops for source
control
do you think the increased difficulty
over github actions
is largely eliminated
i i know basically nothing about azure
dev but yeah i think so i think if
you're already like in
in sort of the azure ecosystem i think
maybe
azure pipelines might might work but
i don't know for sure thank you uh we
have a rather starry eyed question here
important one how did you make these
slides
oh this is just kino with a theme i
found on
online i just googled you know
are there plans and or resources for
using azure pipelines within azure
devops
when testing and checking internal r
packages
i don't know if i got that whole
question are there plans and no
resources for using azure pipelines
within azure devops when testing and
checking internal
internal art packages um so
there are no plans on our team we're
we're in the in terms of the tideverse
team we're very much i think
going to just steer towards github
actions for all of our
all of our repositories um i think
that's probably
for for our for our open source work i
think and we do all of our work on
github so i think it makes a lot of
sense for us
to invest resources there rather than in
azure
thank you can you say something about
your experience of moving from
travis ci to github actions for the
tardives
project yes yes so um
i think such so we we've made travis
the configuration you need for travis
very simple like you can basically just
have language r
and a couple more lines the the workflow
files you use in github actions are a
little bit longer
but i think some people when they're
using travis
um don't understand all the
steps that are going on when you when
you set language are so
part of my motivation for and github
actions was to
make that a little bit more transparent
so it'd be easier for people to
understand exactly what was happening
and and that they could modify it if
they need to
yeah thank you and i think it's time for
one more perhaps
this person is asking a can you mention
krontab
you can schedule kicking off an action
can github actions be used to provide a
package that has data that refreshes
hourly or at some frequency
or are there pros and cons are there
reasons why you would not do that
um you can definitely do that so you can
yeah you can schedule you could schedule
um a github action to so to run hourly
and then deploy like create data and
then deploy it wherever like there's
actually so i didn't talk about any of
this but there's like a whole
marketplace of
custom actions that people have have
developed
for use in github github actions and
they
they can do things like deploy to amazon
s3 or azure cloud or
or wherever basically and you could
so you can basically you can do a lot of
some sophisticated things
with scheduled jobs like that yeah
fantastic final hand for jim jim thank
you very much